Transcriber: shaza elsafi
المدقّق: Nawal Sharabati
بداية من عام 2023،
كم واحدًا منكم قرأ كتابًا؟
حسنًا، ثلاثة كتب؟
هنا ممتاز.
كم واحدًا هذا الأسبوع استمع إلى بثٍ إذاعي؟
القاعة كلها.
أنا ماجد العدواني،
وأشتغل في مجالات البنوك والإعلام
ووسائل التواصل والإذاعية.
نضع كل هذا جانبًا.
جئتُ اليوم لأحدثكم،
عن فرصة وعن واقع
وعن فرص نحن لا نراها أصلًا.
ليس سرًا أن الحضارة الإنسانية
بدأت بثلاث ثورات:
الثورة الأولى، ثورة زراعية؛
بدأ الإنسان يزرع لأنه يريد أن يأكل،
استمرت هذه الثورة، فهي الأطول.
ثانيًا، الثورة الصناعية حيث بدأ الإنسان
يصنع ويبدع ويتألق.
ثالثًا، الثورة التي نعيشها اليوم،
ثورة المعلوماتية
أو ما يسمى بثورة المعلومة.
صراحة لا أعلم إذا ما انتهت إلى الآن،
لأن الجماعة تقول أننا دخلنا في الرابعة.
لكنني سأقف هنا،
الثورة الثالثه.. قائمة على المعلومة،
ومصدرها وتنقلها وسرعتها وأين تصل،
وكيف نحللها وكيف نستفيد منها.
وكانت تاريخيًا تختلف المصادر،
لكن هناك اتفاق على أنّ المصدر
الأساسي هو الكتاب،
وأن الناس يجب أن تقرأ،
وتنقل المعلومات وتناقشها وتحللها .
نحن للأسف كان عندنا ضعف،
أتكلم هنا كمنطقة، كوطن عربي حيث لا نقرأ.
سمعنا كثيرًا إحصائيات،
حيث نقرأ ربع صفحة في السنة.
الإنسان العربي يقرأ ست صفحات،
ولا ادري كل كم فترة.
وعانينا لفترة كبيرة، ويوجد هناك مشاكل
وقضايا ما زالت معلّقة للأسف،
ولسنا قادرين على حلّها بسبب أننا لا نقرأ.
حسنًا، إلى متى نجلسُ،
يعني إلى متى نقف مكاننا دون أن نتحرك.
لكن لدينا شيء في التاريخ لا نراه،
ولا ننتبه إليه وكأنه ليس موجودًا.
تاريخنا مليء بالكلام،
نتحدث قصصًا وحكايات، أشعارًا وبطولات.
واستمر هذا الشيء
معنا مئات السنين، نحكي فقط.
نقول قصصًا، ونقول حكايات حتى أن العرب
قبل ألفي سنة، كان الكلام الثمين
بالنسبة إليهم هي المعلقات،
وهو أقوى إنتاج لغوي
حيث علّقوها على الكعبة.
هذا هو أقوى شيء عندنا.
حسنًا، هذه المعلقات وهذا التاريخ،
هل من الممكن أن نستفيد منه؟
سنستفيد منه إذا أكملنا.
أتعرفون قصة التاجر
الذي اشترى قماشًا اسودًا ولم يباع؟
هل سمعتم بها؟
هناك أشخاص سمعوا بها، لكن ليس كثيرًا.
هناك سخص اشترى قماش يريد أن يبيعه،
قماش لونه أسود، وهو نوع جيد أي منتج جيد،
ولم يكن عنده وسائل تواصل اجتماع هالمسكين،
ولا يوجد محل أي أحد يسمع به.
وكان هناك شاعر من جماعة الكلام،
قال له، أنت وجماعة الكلام تتكلمون جيدًا،
فما رأيك أن تبيع لي
قطع القماس التي نفترش بها
قال له نحن بارعون بالكلام وسأفعلها لك:
“قل للمليحة بالخمارالأسود
ماذا فعلت بناسك متعبد”.
كذّب وزاد عليها بإتقان، وبيع المخزون كله،
وتحسّن الوضع.
لماذا؟ قوة الكلمة.
يعدُ تأثير الكلمة في الثقافة العربية
تأثيرًا كبيرًا نحن لا نحس به.
كذلك العرب عندما يرغبون في إعطاء مثال،
بينما يريدون تأديب شخص ما،
ويرغبون أن يبينوا له أهمية الصديق،
كانوا لا يقولون له أن الصديق مهم،
واحرص على رفيقك وابقى معه.
كانوا يقومون بخلق شخصيات وهمية له مثل،
الغول والعنقاء والخل الوفي .
الغول شخصية مخيفة،
واحد طويل عريض، ولا أدري كيف يبدو.
والعنقاء طير لديه رأس وجسمه مثل العود.
وقالو له أنه من ثالث المستحيلات
أن تلقى الخل الوفي.
فكل هذه القصص ما انتهـت
عند العرب الأوائل وحتى تاريخنا الحديث.
إذا ارادو تخويف الطفل، يقولون له، لا تخرج
إلى الشارع أو الحي، فلا يسمع الكلام.
قالوا له يا طفل أو يا طفلة،
اسمحوا لي يا بنات،
إذا خرجتِ وقت الظهيرة بالحر
سوف تصادفين حيوانًا اسمه حمارة الظهيرة،
واحدة رأسها رأس حمار،
وجسمها جسم إنسان، أعزكم الله!
وهذا لتوصيل رسالة
أن الخروج في الظهيرة يمكن أن يضر.
نفس الشيء، امرأة تمشي ومعها سعف وليف،
تقبض على الأهالي الذين يخرجون في أوقات
غير مناسبة.
كل هذه الأمثلة،
كانت جزءًا من تاريخنا.
وفي نفس الوقت، لا زال عندنا ضعف
في القراءة حيث لا نقرأ، فمشاكلنا عالقة.
لكن نحن اليوم، كما أعتقد،
أمام فرصة تاريخية.
فرصة نقدر فيها أن نرجع لتراثنا،
ونأخذ هذه القاعدة الكلامية
للكلام المتناقل والمتواتر
ونستفيد منها لمعالجة مشاكلنا.
نحن اليوم أمام شيء يسمى البث الإذاعي،
حيث يوجد شخص يشغّل جهاز التسجيل ويناقش،
ويتحدث ويتكلم عن قضايا،
ويحللها ويفككها ويعالجها.
ليس بالضرورة معالجتها،
لكن الأهم أن يناقشها ويتحدث بها.
هذه دعوة إلى النقاش، وإلى الكلام.
كل شعوبنا تسمع، وتسمع جيدًا.
تسمع سياسيين، وتسمع مثقفين
تسمع مثقفين، وتسمع رياضيين.
لكنها شعوب لا تقرأ.
الفرصة التاريخية هذه،
علينا اليوم اقتناصها.
التاريخ لا يقف ولا يعطينا الفرص،
ولا يقول لنا تفضلوا هذه هي الفرصة.
الواجب علينا نحن أن نذهب
إلى الفرصة ونأخذها.
القصد من كل هذا الكلام،
هو إحياء تاريخنا الكلامي المتواتر،
وتوظيفه في فرصة للتقدم.
قد نستفيد منها ونحاول أن نعالج بعض
مشاكلنا العالقة والتي لم نجد لها حلولًا.
أنا شاكر جدًا لحضوركم، وآسف على الإطالة.
شكرًا لكم!
(تصفيق)